but the crowds have been much smaller
throughout the past month
covid19 continues to shrink our economy
forcing our hospitality industry
to really make some major adjustments
thank you for joining us tonight at 11
i'm brian loftis
and i'm denise valdez mgm resorts
announcing hotel
operations will stop at two of its
properties between mondays and thursdays
there's just not enough business
oracle mana joining us now live from the
las vegas strip with more on those
upcoming changes orca
well denise and brian the two hotels
being impacted are the mandalay bay here
behind me
and also the mirage the changes go into
effect on november 30th and while mgm
resort says it doesn't expect
the weekday closures to last too long
experts tell me
that it could be a while and have a big
impact
it's not surprising more properties on
the las vegas strip switching up their
schedules
mgm resorts international announcing the
hotel towers at the mirage and the
mandalay bay will shut down during the
week
monday through thursday due to
underwhelming occupancy amid coven 19.
the key here is it's just the hotels
that are closing hospitality expert
david schwartz says the good news is
both resorts will still operate their
casinos and restaurants that's what park
mgm
is already doing the other amenities are
going to stay open and also they have
mgm has many hotels in the strips they
could redirect those people
to other hotels in a statement mgm
resorts says while they don't expect the
closures to remain past december they'll
continue evaluating business levels to
determine how long they're in effect but
schwartz says demand will depend on how
the pandemic plays out
if the vaccines you rolled out on are
effective i think that's going to be a
big
boon for travel many properties are
still offering lower room rates so even
with covet 19 spiking right now
business experts say price point is key
i think the people will
continue to come the level of supply and
demand
is based on the amount that the consumer
is willing to pay
when the las vegas economy will recover
is uncertain but schwartz says
one thing is clear the city and the
people of the city more importantly have
always bounced back
you'll also remember that the winning
encore announced their weekday closures
last month due to low demand as well
experts tell me that
if there's no significant progress made
in the battle against the coronavirus
soon
more resorts could follow suit reporting
live on the las vegas strip tonight orco
mana 8 news now